[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen wir zu den schuh die
sogenannte übergangs stiefel auch hier
die schule waren schon alle ok aber
nichts was ich wirklich tragen würde ich
glaube die zielgruppe liegt da auch er
bei den älteren da meine mama zum
beispiel die kauft sich jede woche auf
amazon schulreise g alle so hübsch
findet und die alle so toll im angebot
sind und ich habe davon aber keine
zurückgefunden
die übergangs stiefel von doc martens in
weiß die fand ich ganz gut allerdings
haben die 159 95 gekostet und das sogar
nach dem rabatt von ganzen fünf cent
dank amazon wenn ich aber die schuhgröße
43 hätte würde ich nur 94 99 für die
schule zahlen müssen danke mama danke
für schuhgröße 39 was ja viel zu kleines
ich brauche eine außergewöhnliche
schuhgröße um bei amazon günstig
einzukaufen amazon zielgruppe sind
nämlich die außergewöhnlichen menschen
die mit schuhgröße 43 ein bisschen zu
groß für eine frau aber doch genau
richtig aber bei der website abdallah
gab es die schuhe für 92 19 allerdings
weiß ich dass ganz viele fälschungen auf
dem markt existieren und ich glaube bei
einem laden der atari heißt es ich mich
da bin ich eher vorsichtig wo ich aber
auch extrem verwirrt war war bei diesen
schuhen ich mein einer von euch ist
bestimmt ein ganz großer kendall und
kylie jenner fällen sind diese schuhe
echt oder die gibt es nicht die hat
irgendwer gemacht um sie jetzt so dem
namen zu verkaufen
aber diese schuhe sind und nicht von den
produziert also sowie der lippenstift
zum beispiel ihre kategorie musste ich
aus checken partytime irgendwie war mir
die aufmachung ein bisschen zu gut als
dass ich sie ignorieren konnte
deswegen habe ich mich mal dadurch gerät
es ist mir aufgefallen dass ganz viele
partykleider von dieser kuriosen marke
feind vorgeschlagen werden
und dann habe ich mal geschaut was diese
marke eigentlich ist sein meiner
recherche habe ich dann ein eigenes
artikel gefunden und dort wird gesagt
dass feind wie eigenmarke von amazon ist
hätte man sich auch denken kann
ich habe eine theorie und von der lasse
mich nicht mehr abbringen
ich hole mir bald meinen hut denn amazon
für die ganze welt übernehmen amazon
wird uns supermärkte bringen klamotten
alles amazon wird alles produzieren es
wird nichts anderes außer acht so und
irgendwann ist jeder nur noch ein amazon
mitarbeiter
ihr werdet sehen aber kommen wir zu
party klamotten statement röcke was soll
das denn sein
das habe ich mir zuerst gedacht doch
dann habe ich diesen super knoten rott
von desigual gefunden für 25 euro auf
der desigual website hat er bock mal 199
gekostet oh mein gott mein erstes teil
von dir sehen war
aber da sind die läden auch plötzlich
alle aus dem boden gestampft ja ich
denke das ist ein original desigual rock
des super verarbeitet er stoff fühlt
sich gut an
jetzt muss es nur noch gut aussehen
[Musik]
htc ist daran also da war ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt so froh dieses
schnäppchen gemacht zu haben weil ich
finde den rock sehr schön ich habe lange
nach zu einem rock gesucht denen man
einfach anziehen kann und er so der
blickfang eines outfits ist und das
model von deswegen weil es wirklich
zuckersüß abend hosen ich wusste nicht
was ich mir so richtig unter abend hosen
vorstellen kann ich glaube aber das
kommt meiner vorstellung am nächsten und
genau wie bei dem die figur rock habe
ich hier eine riesen schnäppchen
gefunden eine hose für 37 euro und 3
cent dann habe ich mal diese marke
gebügelt und herausgefunden dass es eine
dänische designer marke ist und auf
dieser dänischen designer marken website
wird die hose noch für 160 euro angebot
zwar nicht in schwarz sowie ich jetzt da
hab aber das gleiche muster hat ich
denke mal schwarzes bei den ausverkauft
oder so die ungefähr 123 euro gespart
ich habe noch was von dieser marke feind
gefunden doch über die dänische designer
marke zu ende und dann zeige ich euch
was ich auf amazon vom feind gekauft
habe von der amazon marke denn eben
gerade als ich mich so darüber aufgeregt
haben dass amazon die ganze welt
übernehmen wird habe ich vergessen dass
hier noch was von dieser marke gekauft
habe was ich noch testen möchte aber
feuer testen wir die 160 euro die seine
hose es ist so wird etwas zu kaufen was
man 160 euro gekostet hat und es auch so
eine plastiktüte rauszuholen wo ist mein
sektglas ganz ehrlich ernsthaft mir das
schild lieber thematisiert dass der
aufdruck ist auch drauf die naht sieht
furchtbar aus der stoff ist absolut
billig sorry das soll die seine hose
sein das ist am arsch
die seine hose das ist made in poland
wesens wurde sie in polen gemacht
vielleicht hat meine tante oder soja
daran gesetzt es sieht aus wie ein
billiges kostüm dass man bei amazon
kauft so ein schnelles was man eben mal
kurz braucht weil man jetzt irgendwo
eingeladen wurde und dann holt man sich
irgendwas billiges was dann so kommt mit
diesem komischen knick falten und ich
bin sehr enttäuscht
absolut enttäuschend dieser hose
[Musik]
ich lasse mich jetzt aber nicht von
diesem designer traum herunterziehen
sondern wir checken jetzt noch das
letzte teil aus von feind der eigenmarke
von amazon
ok ich weiß nicht wie sie es hinkriegen
aber es riecht fantastisch es riecht
komplett neutral nach keinem giftstoff
das ist natürlich super crazy mit diesem
band ich bin wirklich gerade überrascht
positiv das hat eine richtig gute
qualität auf dem roten teppich was
tragen sie heute abend
hierzu trägt merkt man eigentlich erst
wie verkackt dieses band ist die wollten
damit so ein bisschen asymmetrischer
cool wirken aber es ist halt falsch
genäht irgendwie ist es einfach nur im
weg ich finde das kleid liegt trotzdem
gut an allerdings ist der stoff so ein
bisschen pyjama stoff also ich würde das
klein glaube ich lieber er hat zum
schlafen tragen als zum ausgehen kommen
wir zum fazit ich habe auf amazon 116
euro 49 bezahlt statt 315 euro 53 das
ist ein gewinn von fast 200 euro
inwiefern man gewinn sagen kann wenn man
trotzdem 116 euro ausgegeben hat dann
ist das ja nicht wirklich geworden 68
eur 69 habe ich nochmal für die beiden
kleider und die jacke ausgegeben denn
feind und jennifer haben wir keinen
vergleichsangebot gehabt da kann man
nicht sparen da kann man das nur für den
preis kaufen und die jagd zalando ja du
zählt nicht so wirklich mit weil die
wollte ich einfach habe jeder online
shop hat hier eigentlich seinen eigenen
preis und amazon ist nicht immer die
günstigste variante hat aber viele gute
chancen um einfach geld zu sparen ich
finde es hier aber noch mal wichtig zu
sagen dass man sich beim shoppen
eigentlich immer die frage stellen
sollte brauche ich das wirklich kauf im
durchschnitt nicht viele klamotten ein
was gut ist denn als ich jünger war war
das noch ganz anders da war das halt
unsere wochenend beschäftigung in die
stadt zu fahren zu h&m reinzulaufen die
angebote zu kaufen man hat er als junger
menschen nicht viel geld deswegen holt
man sich halt die reduzierten klamotten
das ist ja klar was auch in meinem
damaligen kopf ganz in ordnung war ich
dachte ja klar die sind ja im angebot
super ist günstig davon kaufe ich jetzt
richtig viel keiner hat uns damals
wirklich erklärt was es bedeutet dass
die klamotten so günstig dass wir so
einen überschuss an klamotten haben und
sie so günstig einkaufen können bedeutet
dass an einer anderen stelle einen
mangel gibt dass jemand anderes darunter
leiden und es können nicht immer alle
die besten vorzüge aus sachen bekommen
wir müssen aufhören so wahllos klamotten
zu kaufen und bereit sein vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr für etwas auszugeben damit
zeit an anderen stellen einfach besser
laufen kann aber modisch rumzulaufen
soll dadurch nicht kaputt gemacht werden
besten ist es wenn ihr euren eigenen
style finden könnte
und nach dem einkauf nach dem prinzip
weil dann passiert nicht das was uns die
modewelt immer so gerne rein drücken
möchte das ist grad im trend und morgen
ist das im trend und übermorgen brauchst
du umwelt denkt dass die modewelt ist
wirklich böse alle günstigen
modegeschäfte die ihr kennt sind böse
weil sie wollen nicht neue trends
kreieren und irgendwie tolle session
erschaffen sie wollen geld verdienen
dass es ihre mission sie wollen immer
neue sachen raus bringen euch das gefühl
geben dass ihr neue sachen braucht und
somit hört niemals auf zu kaufen also
verdienen alle ganz viel kohle
außer die die klamotten machen müssen
und hinter der ganze produktion steht
die sind am ende immer die die darunter
leiden das war jetzt auch ein
pädagogischer teil zu diesem video ich
dachte wenn ich schon für amazon fashion
so viel werbung mache kann ich aber mal
so ein bisschen richtung pädagogik lane
fahren und mit euch das mal so
besprechen
trotzdem freue ich mich sehr über meine
neue jacke ich weiß dass ich sie lange
tragen werde
ich freue mich sehr über die anderen
sachen die seltsam mit designer hose
werde ich auf jeden fall zurückschicken
und besonders das straußen kleid wenn
das ist sehr eng und so viel werde ich
nicht abnehmen niemals kennt ihr das
ich nehme noch ab aber dieses mal nicht
und ich habe bock von desigual das für
dich super bis dahin leute schreibt es
mir mal die kommentare wie das video
findet und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder in den links in den
beschreibungen sind die links zu den
klamotten sind appelliert links ich
werde beteiligt aber